come on y'all already know it that you
have oh [ __ ] is don't front we I think
we had the same idea I tried to read it
but I think I already know I agree with
[Applause]
coming back
these red pill [ __ ] he was dead
he went out to the galaxy uh-huh uh-huh
you got it got it back came back with a
quickness before they gave it sister to
[ __ ] range Pro that makes sense which
Korea's closest to space South Korea so
far exactly let's you go under it
Columbus plan so she's going up either
way spaces that's kim jeong-hoon no all
right no you can't hold him down bro you
know my man enough stop son bro what is
UFO stand for own identify
Oh
flight is better than [ __ ] but in all
seriousness hoon is back baby is he
are you sure because you can't kill
what's already dead
oh are you sure he no no I know him Joe
Lunas back yeah well you think exquisite
us they he came back the same day to
Rodman should drop mm-hmm
that young be honest one out plays that
sound effect the joy that go through his
body
son of a DJ and now one second [ __ ]
kidding in all seriousness you can't
stop kim jeong-hoon
he's gonna be here forever that's what
he is yo I mean yeah he gotta be around
forever he Asian he's aged 104 that's my
[ __ ] guy bro
we might have to go to North Korea he's
numero uno yo think about it
think about it should we go to North
Korea we could do that I'd go you could
go there's trips
I'd go Rodney came back yeah but that's
Rodman yo son what's the difference seen
Rodman Kim Jong Rodman what if we go
there and then we win his heart we could
try to win his heart I think we sent him
some videos I bet if we sent him this
video he'd be like you know what these
guys I mm-hmm just guys scour the rest
of your [ __ ] make sure there's no jokes
about the man I think that he could take
a joke I think that he has an
exceptional sense of yes this is the
rock this is about thought trans never
really you think you have an exceptional
driving here's an exceptional go
quite a funny prank he played on us
[Laughter]
right it's not it's pretty good as far
as pranks go every death is pretty good
that's it he was please playing
peek-a-boo yo that's a great political
leader to fake your own death son that's
not a velly sometimes you got to do that
to see how much the people really [ __ ]
with you
I mean you faked your own death and you
see all your man's right there that said
they loved you and then they're out
there like nah [ __ ] that I'm glad he's
dead his sister's way better Oh word Oh
word on Tom Sawyer on it that's it was
that Huckleberry Finn Oh Tom I can't
remember bro
hey guys Huck Finn I think I think my
man Hawks did that warm hugs was
chilling his own funeral yo Hawks was
chilling watching it go down very fin
norok Kimbrough have a berry King here
dawg yeah great all I gotta say is the
guys ahead of his time put some respect
on him that's all I'm saying a little
bit respect try to see it from his eyes
it's hard to do
[Applause]